All right. There's this woman named
Christine who decided to feed her family
of six for an entire week using x amount
of dollars. I'm gonna let you guess how
much money she used. 300? No. How about
100? Not even. She decided to only use
$30 to feed her whole family for an
entire week. So, if you're taking six
people times three meals a day for 7
days in a week, that is 126 meals. And
if you guys don't know Christine, she's
better known as the frugal fit mom. I'll
put the link to her original video in
the description, but this was a
challenge that she took on back in 2020,
which now has over 2.4 million views.
The only food items she used outside of
her $30 budget was salt, pepper, and oil
for cooking. Other than that, she really
did stay true to this $30 budget. But
like, how? This is literally 24 cents
per meal throughout this entire week.
And I'll be honest, seeing the creative
meals that she came up with, that is
making me rethink my entire grocery
budget. I'm going to walk you through
Christine's exact strategies from her
Walmart haul, and we're going to see if
this is actually realistic for people
today. So, the first strategy that I'm
taking from her challenge is the from
scratch approach. Before diving into the
actual grocery list, let's look at the
mindset shift that made everything
possible. Christine had this idea that
she was going to buy raw ingredients
over the finished products. For example,
instead of buying a whole loaf of bread,
she decided to buy flour and yeast,
which she could create way more servings
with. She also refused to buy actual
tomato sauce and decided to go with
tomato paste that she could convert into
way more tomato sauce. And finally,
instead of buying chicken broth up
front, she bought chicken bon which she
could again convert into more chicken
broth. And thankfully, in the case of
bread, Christine actually dropped the
recipe for her no need bread. And if you
are a home bread maker as well, let us
know your recipes in the comments. Her
second strategy had to do with the
biggest protein hack. One thing that
makes any meal feel complete is having
protein. So, when she first entered
Walmart, she grabbed this big old 10 lb
bag of chicken leg quarters. All right,
fast forward. It's 2025 and Ashley and I
are looking for those chicken leg
quarters. Let's see if they even sell
them. Oh, you found them right here. Oh,
snap.
All right, here we go. 10 lb bag of
chicken leg quarters. Today, they are
$7.72.
Honestly, I thought it'd be more
expensive. It's not a bad cut of meat.
Maybe we should get those. Before
watching this video, I haven't even
considered that as my meat of choice.
But turns out because it's bone in,
because the skins included, this not
only works as a very cheap cut of meat,
but when you cook it, you end up
creating some great chicken broth as
well. But there's also another reason
why chicken leg quarters were a
strategic move. A chicken leg quarter is
the thigh and drumstick of a chicken.
So, we're talking about dark meat here,
which obviously tastes better. argue
with me in the comments, but there's
also a higher fat content, which makes
this cut of meat way more filling. All
right, that's that's enough of that. And
boy, do you realize how adaptable a
chicken leg quarter is to all the
different meals out there. Christine
ended up making a chicken and rice
casserole, a chicken pot pie, as well as
a chicken noodle soup. So, if you're
really tight with your budget, you can
get very creative with one cut of meat
that might be affordable compared to
buying a whole beef tri tip. And since
we're talking about protein, she did
also buy three dozen eggs for $3.76,
which I am totally jealous of, even
though this was only back in 2020. All
right, so we found the three dozen eggs.
Looks like they are now costing $8,
which is a little more than double the
price back in 2020. And surprisingly,
this is cheaper than what it was 2
months ago. So, let the community know
in the comments what is your biggest
sources of protein when you go grocery
shopping. Right now, my wife and I are
rocking the chicken breasts, but maybe
chicken leg quarters is something we'll
consider. Strategy three, fuel that
fills up. There are a lot of cheap
filling carb options out there. For
example, Christine chose this 3 lb pack
of spaghetti, 5 lbs of rice for only
$2.22
and 2 lb of dried pinto beans. If you've
watched Dave Ramsey even for a little
bit, you've probably heard the phrase
beans and rice and rice and beans,
especially when you're on a tight
budget.
>> A beans and rice cookbook. No, it's it's
a it's a metaphor.
>> It's a metaphor.
>> And I'll be honest, that meal, rice and
beans, it's pretty bomb. It's a complete
nutritious meal in itself, and you can't
really hate on it. Literally, Hispanics
eat that all the time. And by the way,
one thing I loved out of her meal list
was just plain old oatmeal. She bought
the classic Quaker Oats cylinder and
made breakfast for a few mornings for
her entire family and just sprinkled
some chopped apples on top of that
oatmeal. For me, oatmeal is like the
elixir of life. As someone with a family
history of high blood pressure, once I
start eating a bowl of oatmeal
consistently, all my levels literally
like go back to normal. Let me know if
you felt the same experience, too. But
oatmeal is great. It's super filling.
And of course, with those apples
sprinkled on top, it makes it taste, you
know, less like cement. Strategy four,
concentrated flavor. Now, I really don't
think about this, but I think this is
where Christine's motherly instincts
really kick in. She focused on buying
concentrated flavors. Like I mentioned,
tomato paste and chicken bon
billion. How do you pronounce that?
>> Let's say it all together. Buyon.
>> Buy.
>> One more time. Buyon.
>> Buyon.
>> Now, let's
>> But yeah, that chicken buon ended up
giving her 12 cups of chicken broth,
which is a huge bang for your buck. My
only issue, though, is with that tomato
paste, she made this sauce for her pasta
dish. But like, what is that? You know,
I I know she had a lot of restrictions.
She did the best she really could, but
like it just looks sad. And that's why
later in this video, we are going to
talk about how realistic this challenge
is for us today. Strategy five, planning
before purchasing. Even though this was
just a YouTube challenge, and it wasn't
something she would sustain for a long
period of time, she demonstrated the
ultimate meal plan. It's not like she
just walked into Walmart and improvised
what ingredients she would buy to stay
under $30 for the whole week. She had to
meticulously think about which meals she
was going to make, which meals could add
variety, which ones could be more
filling, and which ones did not require
expensive ingredients. A lot of times we
end up grocery shopping. We think about
this recipe we saw on Facebook or Tik
Tok, and then we suddenly decide we need
this cut of meats or this ingredient
because Tik Tok said so. That could lead
us to us being very inefficient with our
grocery shopping. Instead, we need to do
our planning before we even take step
into the grocery store. Check your
pantries, your fridges, and see what
ingredients you already currently have.
Then define what are the two to four
dishes I want to make throughout this
week. And finally, write out the
ingredients that you actually need in
order to make these dishes before you
even go into the grocery store. A couple
resources I've been using to decide what
meals I could make with my current
ingredients is Tik Tok and even ChatGpt.
And I know my Gen Z is really showing
here, but don't knock it. If you
seriously have only certain ingredients
like uh cottage cheese, curry powder,
and lentils, I bet if you plug that into
Chat GPT, it could come up with a meal
for you. You know what? Let's do that
right now. Hey, ChachiPT, I only have
cottage cheese, lentils, and curry
powder in my pantry. What could I make
out of these three ingredients?
Boom. Curried lentils with cottage
cheese soup. curried lentil and cottage
cheese dip/spread.
All right, someone better cook this and
send me a picture. We actually have the
Frugal Rich Facebook group. We've had
people upload pictures of their grocery
list, different meals they've made, and
we love for you to join. It's completely
free. Link in the description. Strategy
six, the leftover feast. Christine made
multiple big meals throughout this
challenge, and I remember on one night
in particular, she just laid out the
Tupperware full of the leftovers. It was
spaghetti, chicken pot pie, and chicken
rice casserole. I absolutely loved that
she did this. Guys, it is no longer the
1950s where it's all stay-at-home moms
making huge feasts for their families. I
know we all get busy. I know we got
things to do, so don't put so much
pressure on yourself when it comes to
presentation. You're feeding your
family, so that is already a win. So,
who cares what's displayed or what the
combinations of food is? They're just
kids, right? And husbands are usually
not that picky. I'm sorry if they are,
but this is actually a core memory for
me as well. Back when I was growing up,
every Sunday would be our leftover day.
We would just take out all the leftovers
from the fridge, throw them in serving
plates, heat them up in the microwave,
and then we would enjoy them with our
own little bed of rice each. That's how
we avoided food waste each week. And to
be honest, I enjoyed those days.
Sometimes food is even better after it's
been sitting in the fridge. All right,
but let's get real for a second here.
How sustainable is this type of grocery
shopping and meal planning? Do you think
in 2025 we could still feed a family of
six for an entire week with only $30?
Well, based off prices nowadays, I think
no. But I really do want to applaud the
frugal fit mom back in 2020 for doing
this challenge and for not bending the
rules to fit her needs. She did this
whole challenge in such a classy way.
She didn't come across like, "Oh, I'm
going to be poor for a week." She
literally just wanted to share some
ideas of what meals you could make for a
large family if you do have a very
limited budget. And honestly, shout out
to her kids and her husband for dealing
with these kinds of meals cuz once
again, what is that? I honestly would
have been okay with her using some of
the seasoning she already had, but she
wanted to stay so true to the challenge
that I just got to respect her for it. I
just have to note though, if you have a
picky spouse or picky children, this
challenge might not work for you. But
then again, it's either you eat this or
you starve, so you better eat it. And my
other thought on the reality of this
challenge is that if you look at the
meals she made, where were the fresh
fruits and vegetables? If your budget
really is that strict, yeah, you
definitely have to cut out some very
nutritious ingredients out of your diet.
But for most people, you probably don't
really have to do that. There are great
resources out there like food pantries
and churches that are always giving out
food to those people who do really need
it. And honestly, there is really no
shame to using those resources. I
remember graduating from high school. Me
and a few friends would volunteer at
some of these food pantries, and they
had some nice stuff. So, if providing
food for your family is really in crisis
mode right now, please go and use the
resources out there. I'm sure you can
find them on Facebook. And if you have
experience with volunteering or even
using these food pantries for yourself,
let us know how that went for you in the
comments. For my wife and I, we stick to
a pretty minimal grocery list. If you
want to see what we buy every single
week, click on this video right here and
I'll break it all down for you. Other
than that, if you haven't joined the
Frugal Rich Community Facebook group,
join for free in the description. See
you guys there. Peace.